[Music]
hey everybody how's it going its let you
go so today I thought I'd do a favorites
video I've never done one before I think
and I really like watching them on
YouTube so I figured why not there's
also just a lot of stuff that I really
like this month I think a lot of it has
to do with my mood being better and it's
spring and sunnier oh yeah I just wanted
to talk about it because I get really
excited talking about things that I
really like it's gonna be a good
combination of like products and
experiences sort of but I'm not
sponsored by any of the products or
experiences but I will be leaving links
to everything in the description box
below I'm like so new to this I like
don't know where to start but maybe I'll
start with this so I think the first
thing I'm gonna talk about is this super
cool pea Anika that I bought I bought
this on Amazon I really wanted a piano
for a long while I think they're just
like fun and compact and like the sound
is really fun I don't have like a full
piano at home I also don't really play
piano and kind of little around with it
but this is just kind of like the
perfect medium for me it's just like
playing music when I want to and it's
super compact a nice and cute and sweet
so I'm glad I bought it it was like 20
bucks on Amazon
alright how very cool
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's do the next thing maybe I'll
talk about other music things well kind
of we're in the vein of this so my other
favorite is the greatest showmen
soundtrack now if you follow me on like
Instagram and Twitter and stuff you all
know about this but like I am obsessed
with the soundtrack I washed out on the
plane all the way to Japan in April and
then I wash I was kinda like oh yeah
it's fine
pots alright and then the other day I
was writing the train home and I was
just like hey I haven't actually given
the greatest showmen soundtrack a Chan
and so I listened to it and like it was
like explosive in my head I was like
this is so good
granted the songs are like pretty poppy
but that's the stuff that I really like
but like it gives me so much energy I
use it to like hype myself up and stuff
so that ayahuasca do that I shot last
week I was like listening to the
greatest showmen and just like pumping
myself up so I think it's a great
soundtrack with like an okay movie but
all the covers on YouTube are also
amazing that's really I think like the
thing that I love about the greatest
showmen soundtrack one of my favorites
this month it's so good I love it okay
so the next thing that's kind of like
more music related is I joined an
acapella group and this is just like an
acapella group that some people at work
just put together and we've only met
like twice but it is so much fun I think
I just spit everywhere I'm so excited
yeah it is so much fun I was actually
never part of like an acapella group in
high school in college like I didn't do
choir or acapella or anything like that
cuz I was like I need to be focused now
you do like engineering stuff because
that's the stuff that's gonna look good
on my college resume so it's kind of
like I don't know like if I want to be
inquiry or not cappella and stuff but
now that I'm an adult and I'm working
and I have the privilege of being able
to kind of do what I want
I've been doing acapella at work and it
is so fun the people who are in the
group are also really cool like there's
some of my most favorite people at
patreon making music with other people
is a beautiful thing and that's why I
love doing Orchestra from middle school
high school and then a little bit
through college
and having that as part of my life again
is giving me this renewed energy and
passion and realization that I just like
really love music honestly I think
that's why I like about this and
greatest showmen is meaning a lot for me
but I feel like I'm doing something
because I like to do it and I'm trusting
my gut and I'm following what I think is
fun so I'm having a lot of fun and yeah
definitely one of my favorite things
this month I also only have like 30
minutes to shoot this because I'm gonna
go to dinner with some friends I'm
really excited about okay I have another
music related one you can tell that a
theme here is that this month I have
just been like getting so much energy
from music and that's been kind of just
like giving me all of the excitement and
enthusiasm and energy for life my last
music one is Natalia laughs for khadi
I hold saying that right I love food
Cuddy I really oh gosh she's amazing
she's a artist from Mexico I think like
her music is kind of like bossa nova ish
but also kind of acoustic ish but also
has like that Latin Mexican feel and I
love it so much
my brother actually introduced me to her
she did an NPR tiny desk concert and
that was amazing like she just looks
like she's having so much fun playing
music and her band is also incredible
they're so multi-talented I think it's
like a perfect like intro to summer
beginning of summer end of spring tide
the soundtrack I'm actually like trying
to learn some of the music maybe I'll do
yeah it just reminds me of like being
San Diego where I'm from and just like
chilling and having a good time and
appreciating life
my favorite songs are so let da de Mar
so it does yo ma and pas de que su free
both of those are so good as well as
like a lot of other songs but definitely
check her out
I love her music and I hope you do next
up is like an actual tangible thing and
is this it is my Libas jean jacket it's
just like the regular women's trekker
jacket looks like this on the back and
in a small and I really like it a lot oh
it's been a while since I had an actual
jean jacket I think maybe the last time
I had a dream jacket was like when I was
a kid maybe like 12
not even I think like eight or nine and
I got one for my birthday because Lisa
Loya was like my idol and I loved her
and at the time that was right when I
started wearing glasses so I also had
the tortoise like frame glasses and I
got a jean jacket and a guitar and I was
like I'm Lisa Louis so it's been a while
since I owned one but they're so in
right now so I went on Amazon and bought
it and I think it was about $60 and yeah
it's pretty soft it actually keeps me
pretty warm I think I got off on a hot
day like on a pretty warm day then like
this is all I need
unfortunately I can't layer with it but
I mean this alone had so much like
personality that I liked it a lot so
yeah when I wear it looks like this I've
actually been posting like oot Dee's
outfit of the days on my Instagram
stories I'm just like what I wear to
work and you'll see this come up a lot
but I like it a lot so it's more my face
okay
next is another clothing item and this
one are my wide green pets but it looks
like a skirt but it's actually pants
see I actually got this in Japan when I
went and it came as a set with like one
of those like striped shirts but it was
like a crop top and I really like this
it's super comfortable like I don't
really like wearing jeans because
they're not comfortable but I wear them
anyways but this is like a game changer
and I like how like right here it's like
well done here and so when I wear it up
here it looks really nice but yeah this
is actually kind of a bold fashion
purchase for me because I'm pretty like
conservative when it comes to clothing
it's usually like t-shirt jeans which
I'm trying to change and so I bought
this and I was like I don't know if I'm
actually gonna wear it and then I have
like at least once a week and I love
them because I don't know they make me
feel a little more like feminine and
they're super fun to wear and they're
really
and I also love this color green so the
brand is called earth music and ecology
I don't know if they have an online
store but they had a store near where my
parents live so I went in I think they
have similar ones at like unique low and
other places but I love the flare pant
trend so maybe I'll get some more the
next one is something I've been doing
for the last two weekends and it's
surfing as some of you know I grew up in
San Diego but I didn't ever really learn
how to surf during my whole time there
so it kind of feels like I'm buying back
lost time sort of by learning how to
serve and last weekend I rode one wave
for like four seconds and that was all I
caught but it was super fun I didn't
know how to stop but I just like fell
off the board yeah it's been really fun
it's actually like it's a lot it
requires a lot of muscles that I don't
have and it's also like making me tan
and weird places like the wetsuit tan is
giving me this weird line but I have a
lot of fun with it
I just feel so good after surfing and
like having a burrito afterwards so I'm
excited to do more about this summer I'm
actually going to San Diego this weekend
so I'm hoping to catch some waves there
that's another favorite of mine this
next one kind of related to surfing it's
like kind of silly but it's this
sunblock it's just like the Hawaiian
Tropic shear touch sunblock and there's
nothing super special about it it's SPF
50 which is like really strong but the
thing that I really like about it is
that it's all in Spanish because I
bought it in Cancun last year when I
went for fourth of July and I still use
it because there's a lot left but like
something about the fact that it's like
sunscreen from Cancun makes me think
that it works better and they totally
sell this in America too but I really
like it and yeah like I can't I don't
understand it but it's sunblock and I I
don't know it's just like a silly thing
that I like so sunblock from Cancun I
wonder if it actually works better than
some block from like here so my last
favorite thing this month is phone calls
with friends so I was in like high
school when Facebook came out and so
like through middle school and early
high school like I would always just
like call friends and
like talk for like three to five hours
like get in fights with my brother about
who gets to use the line but it was
really fun cuz you just like don't even
really think about it you just talk
about soap your friends and sometimes
you've got it sometimes you talk about
really deep life things sometimes talk
about homework but yeah this times are
really fun and you know with like text
messaging and social media and stuff
like I haven't called people in a long
time granted like I call my parents and
stuff and we FaceTime and like that's a
separate thing but like phone calls with
friends is something that I haven't done
in a while yeah so this actually
happened was my friend Amy Amy codes
actually who you all know from the cloud
that I did with her I was texting her
one night and I was like Amy this really
because I didn't think happened she's
like tell me all about it and I was like
can I just call you because I think
that'll be quicker that way and I called
her and we talked for like an hour about
a bunch of different things and I was
like this is nice not needing to worry
about what exact words I'm gonna say and
just kind of like trusting the flow of
the conversation as well it was really
nice I don't know
I think these more analog experiences
bring me a lot of fulfillment so I want
to do more of those definitely one of my
favorite moments this month cool well
thank you all so much for watching I
hope you liked today's video let me know
if you want to see more of these I guess
like if you want to know about what I
meant to in a month I actually I mean I
think I like I will like making these
because if anything it documents what I
like from once a month yeah I hope you
all liked it too and if you did give it
a thumbs up comment down below for what
your favorite thing was this month I
guess yeah I don't know let me know how
you're doing comments are the way that I
know that you know how y'all are doing
and just like who you are so don't be
afraid to say hi and as always don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
also turn on the notification Bell for
notifications for new videos I probably
should get to dinner soon so I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]